bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia la era de angela merkel que
abarca 16 años como la líder de la mayor
economía de europa llega a su fin la
canciller alemana entrega a su cargo por
voluntad propia al no postularse a las
elecciones de este 26 de septiembre de
2021 y luego de haber ganado cuatro
legislaturas anteriores que le valieron
ser la líder europea más influyente del
siglo 21 física de profesión angela
merkel viró hacia la política con la
caída del muro de berlín en 1989 un
parteaguas de su carrera en 1990 se
convirtió en diputada del bundestag la
cámara baja del parlamento alemán fueron
años de intensa lucha política a favor
del clima y la reducción de gases de
efecto invernadero para el año 2000 fue
elegida como presidente de la unión
demócrata cristiana de alemania el
partido socialdemócrata con el cual
logró en cuatro oportunidades formar
exitosas coaliciones de gobierno que
comenzaron en el 2005 en dicho año
merkel se convirtió en la primera mujer
alemana en ser escogida para el cargo
político más alto de su país el de
canciller
la llegada de angela merkel a la cabeza
de la cuarta mayor economía del mundo la
puso en un escenario de codo a codo con
otros grandes líderes mundiales de la
época como george bush vladimir putin
jacques chirac y tony blair las
reuniones del g8 ahora contaban con una
mujer entre su selecto club de quien se
alabó su diplomacia y su estilo
negociador tras un brillante comienzo en
el g8 de san petersburgo de 2006
merkel fue la anfitriona del g8 en 2007
en la ciudad báltica de heiligendamm
donde apalancó su lucha para erradicar
la pobreza mundial en especial la de
áfrica a través de la inversión la
innovación y la sostenibilidad
pero un año más tarde en 2008 detonaría
la crisis económica mundial que para
angela merkel implicaría uno de los
retos más grandes de toda su carrera
política hablamos de la gran recesión
cuyo origen se remonta a eeuu con la
quiebra del banco lehman brothers la
explosión de la burbuja inmobiliaria
estadounidense producto de las hipotecas
de alto riesgo que expandieron la
desconfianza crediticia en los mercados
financieros acabó quebrando a una serie
de bancos de inversión con lo cual miles
de personas perdieron su empleo una
crisis económica que no demoraría en
presentar síntomas en europa como
sucedió con la falta de liquidez y el
desplome de las bolsas en países como
españa portugal italia y grecia con
varias de las economías del
mediterráneo' sumidas en la crisis
merkel impuso severas y estrictas
medidas de austeridad para todo el
bloque la denominada crisis del euro
obligó a ciertos países a ajustarse el
cinturón y el caso más sonado fue el de
grecia cuya deuda soberana desplomó la
bolsa de atenas y profundizó la
desconfianza de los acreedores la
economía griega estaba en un punto de no
retorno ante dicho panorama y merkel
tuvo que tomar una de las decisiones más
clave de su mandato europeo o dejar caer
a grecia o rescatarla a punta de
multimillonarios préstamos merkel y solo
segundo poniendo a prueba su capital
político para convencer a sus padres de
que grecia no podía abandonar la zona
euro la resolución de merkel en la toma
de decisiones ya se había visto unos
años atrás en 2011 tras el accidente
nuclear de fukushima en japón
paso a paso dejaremos de usar la energía
nuclear por completo para finales de
así como alemania dejaba de ser un país
nuclear por decisión de merkel unos años
más tarde y también por su de nuevo el
país germano se convertiría en el hogar
de un millón de refugiados en 2015 miles
de refugiados de medio oriente y el
norte de áfrica escaparon de las guerras
de sus países de origen como la de siria
y libia el masivo éxodo hacia europa
provocó trágicos sucesos con cientos de
muertos
en el mediterráneo o congelados en
camiones frigoríficos
además la suerte de miles de emigrantes
estaba en entredicho ante el impávido
gestionar europeo y el rechazo directo
de países como hungría el cual construyó
un muro en su frontera con serbia para
impedirles el paso en dicha crisis de
refugiados la noticia de que alemania
mantendría sus puertas abiertas para
recibirlos y proveerles asilo legal nos
llenó de esperanza permítanme decir
simplemente que alemania es un país
fuerte y nuestra intención es la de
saber que hemos logrado tanto que lo
lograremos
podemos manejar esto y donde hay
obstáculo tenemos que superarlo pero era
tal el flujo migratorio que merkel
recibió además de un millón de
emigrantes un aluvión de críticas de sus
vecinos europeos y de políticos alemanes
de la oposición que no querían la
llegada de los migrantes
y
para ser sincera si tenemos que empezar
a disculparnos por mostrar una cara
amistosa en tiempos de crisis entonces
este mes mi país
en retrospectiva y según expertos lo he
hecho por merkel evitó una crisis
humanitario de refugiados en el corazón
de europa pero le costó en su propio
país el ascenso vertiginoso del grupo de
extrema derecha a efe de una lucha que
dejó en claro su determinación política
pero sobre todo su carácter humanitario
como el demostrado durante la pandemia
de coronavirus
lamentablemente tengo que volver a
decirlo hoy la situación es grave muy
grave y todos debemos tomarnos la enseña
la tercera ola de la pandemia tiene a
nuestro país firmemente en sus garras
tras atravesar todo tipo de crisis y sin
olvidar las del orden político como la
salida del reino unido- de la unión
europea angela merkel entrega a alemania
con un rico legado económico y social
además de un legado de inspiración para
los jóvenes que luchan por el clima y
las mujeres que se forman puestos en
espacios de dominación masculina así
terminamos con este breve recorrido en
la historia política de angela merkel
soy andrés suárez jaramillo a ustedes
gracias por compartir estas historias
que las encuentran en france 24 punto
com
a
[Música]